for two weeks protests have taken to the
streets of panama
demanding the government take action to
combat the high cost of living
prices of gasoline medicine and basic
food items have doubled since the start
of
until they sit down with us to discuss
and find solutions to this unsustainable
situation
teachers were the first to demonstrate
at the start of july but they have since
been joined by construction workers
students and members of indigenous
groups in the central province of
viraguas protesters blocked the
pan-american highway affecting access of
goods to the panama canal from other
central american countries president
laurentino corteso blamed kovid in the
war in ukraine for the cost hikes he
promised to reduce the price of gasoline
by 24
and freeze the cost of 10 basic food
items to try and dissuade protesters
one of the problems now hitting
panamanians and the world is rising fuel
prices and the consequences for that
reason i set up talks to address high
fuel costs directly impacting the cost
of staple foods with the objective of
finding concrete and feasible solutions
but on tuesday protesters called the
offer insufficient demanding larger
reductions and vowed to keep up their
pressure on the streets
analysts say the problem lies in an
unequal economic recovery following the
pandemic
the macro numbers are based on a few
items logistics the national airline
mining and the panama canal but the
growth did not trickle down to the
population while prices went up so
working class panamanians are wondering
why if the country is growing at 6.5
percent they are unable to pay for
medicine and gasoline
the government is hoping for
negotiations with union leaders but for
now more demonstrations are planned and
a national strike is set to go ahead on
wednesday alessandra
al jazeera